I know you guys can't wait to buy the
bond but we've got to wait until you
know the appeals court makes a decision
on that that's been basically the rule
of the game ever since that's what our
law says that's what judge we say said
he would do but then there's always the
court of appeals so there's a hearing on
April 13th luckily it was not an april
fool's day we would have liked that
hearing to have taken place earlier on
and when I say we it's not just us but
also the holdouts that was not the case
but well you know it will happen when it
it will happen and once that is out of
the way we'll
will basically issue the bond and
therefore everyone will be happy that
you'll have your own share of the bomb
well it's funny that you bring up the
timing because you have questions about
that too so I just say there's the
appeal surprisingly the appeals court
April 13th there's a deadline the
current deadline for paying off the
holder that's as April 14th so how are
you able to do that no that is over the
deadline is for one group of holdouts
not for all of the whole else just for
one group and it's not a deadline is a
is a strike basically I mean it's it's
option day if you will and it's their
option to stay in the deal or to leave
the deal and it's their option there's
nothing we can do about that but you
know is there a chance that the whole
nail could fall apart if the payment is
not made by AT&T I don't see why that
would be the case because I don't see
why the holdouts would decide to hold
out of hold out well date is a date a
deadline fine gesture I mean we've done
we've done what we were required to do I
mean we've agreed on the terms we pushed
the law through Congress we had to say
in English it's a horrible work we
repealed the law that we needed to
repeal and we're ready to ready to go
but you know is there any mechanism
needed just either maybe just a great
extension for example is a little
personality it's again you guys know
about financial options this is an
option that we don't have we've given
that option away so it's for the
holdouts to exercise or not exercise the
option I mean I think it would be the
wrong decision to exercise the option
and it's the court judge grease a was
very clear about what he said he said
that when the two conditions are met and
the two conditions being
the laws that are needed and those guys
who have a current agreement that was
signed before or on februari 29th once
we paid for these guys the injunction
will be removed so it's very clear to me
what what the value of that option is is
there any chance that you would use
reserves that they look silly in the
previous I mean we can't pay until the
Court of Appeal ratifies worth what the
judge said so once the Court of Appeal
ratifies will do what it takes to to to
pay but I don't know i don't think we
will be able to issue a bond in in one
day